partita a proprio favore
per la difesa si si si
allora io 4 milioni di iscritti quindi
se voglio mangiare le patatine in live
me ne sbatto i [__]
ok sempre dio adesso io un ora mangio
patatina una frangia zitti zitti
continente ci sono dei problemi of youth
work out no hai mai letto non scriveremo
mia ciao ciao belli come state tutto
bene
io allora vi spiego sono trovato le
vacanze tipo sono tornato tipo un'oretta
fa
e siccome il video per oggi non son
riuscito a farlo ho detto facciamo una
live visto che poi non ce l'ho evitiamo
che non c'è mai voglia di dare un cazzo
io e niente siamo in line oggi quindi la
gara rientro dalle vacanze così anche
perché comunque io quando rientro dopo
un po che non gioco a niente
l'impiego un attimino a rimettermi in
sesto più di una rai che fa più che bene
oggi c'è pietro che messana pastai
messaggiando mio avviso c'è pietro che
vi dà una mano visto che non mi dicono
che quello che youtuber sono quando
arrivato un po che non faccio video
quindi siamo siamo in due sai che mi si
sono attaccate tutte le patatine ai
denti e andare a prendere l'acqua
il live vabbè magari non facciamo super
chat si sa come e non lo so ma grazie ai
10 euro
non c'erano le donazioni alessandro
manovra spettava spero non donate che
non possiamo leggerle non opero pensavo
se attiva la super mi chiama unico
youtuber che non donate quale io giudice
non donate grazie alessandro no è che
non pensavo ci fosse la super certo
attiva
quindi basta a donare soldi che voi non
vi leggiamo simone ciao simone sto bene
oddio questa disattiva della gente ma i
soldi non li voglio i soldi che schifo i
soldi poi mandare tutti sono baciate non
donate perché non riesco non riusciamo a
leggerlo
la leggiamo troppo tardi quindi grazie
comunque molto gentili e madonna che
capelli merdare e giochiamo perchè la
lascia per io ho bisogno in bottiglia la
donate per farmi lavare i denti che sono
nella merda ci siamo che non sono basse
che mostri marche non siamo una kim line
o camila adesso iniziamo era solo che
qua mi calcio abbiamo tanti negli orari
e di evidente a sentire parecchio 29
dico va bene dagli siamo raga non
importa anche se in genere vinicio
quando siamo sui 25 sticazzi perché oggi
questo può giocare anche perché sono
tipo in astinenza da due settimane
perché voi avete visto il video uscire
ma in realtà non stavo giocando i giorni
preparati e li ho aiutati nel mentre
quindi ti sei uomo slogan non donante
basta
grazie va anche bene la pedata di jason
se non vale tutti i 20.000 spettatori
sono la pedata non solo gli iter fetta
dagli atti o intere parti del cazzo sei
ecco
ti sei mai sicuro i sistemi di parte ma
come minimo sei sotto profili ma tanto
valeva rapito però nel senso non
troveremo le partite per l'hardware ma
c'è un problema che plancia e non c'è
l'audio attaccato il cielo si sente raga
perfetto ecco non sente cazzi suoi
non sono diverse ma le cuffie non sono
attaccate non sei capace espandano
trascina madonna come l'altra volta li
na bambina reidy ma anche dei domato ma
è che il pomodoro a mi metto flyng sono
l'ambiente che aggiunge perché io non ho
niente per è di per sé che lo farei di
rallentato di cambio ha chiarito a
digiuno non più schifo però le contadine
in mano già fatto il caso che ho
dell'olio in faccia ora però 4 milioni
di iscritti mary merito dai tatro non so
se saremo jason o meno sti casi o guarda
alcuna dobbiamo vi una una una dobbiamo
vincere una sola né che possano sempre
bello
sport come mi ricordo ultimate in live
abbiamo detto no sì allora la mia
signora si vince o se lo fanno ready non
fanno ready non fanno re di sacrificio
propri entro vent'anni entrare beni che
bisogna usare maniere forti
ha funzionato subito come si sorride
europea io non sono scappata
nell'inglese quale c'era la renzi come
insegnante d'inglese nel supremo
grazioso non vuoi fare you tube
professionista
no troppo tra l'altro notato che nelle
live ragazzi si vede meglio che nei
video normali molti me l'avete chiesto
perché è la risposta che non lo so però
fatevelo andar bene nel pool so perché
si vede meglio
l'audio del gioco bus sarà alto buon uso
mike detto metto secondo me lui jason
bastardo dal nome lo vedo molto
non mi piace soprattutto è una figura
tra l'altro ma perché qualche messaggio
a jason punto essere ciechi è ovvio non
lo so sembra mio ex compagno di classe a
un peruviana e dentro giuro uguale dati
sono l'unica tipa quasi siamo in due
se sei jason che a mappare il bama non
fare dell'apparato potrei essere
indietro salì al bianco classica che mio
padre non penso anche madonna ttt
strappo anche l'intestino
leggo l'intestino al collo e lancia una
nuova moda che chiara ferragni si deve
solo spostare due ministeri genere che
ti faccio un culo madonna dove sono i
bagnanti bastardi è vedere come si torna
dalle vacanze voleva farli stronzi che
mi divido in sordina ma george minuti
cisco semmai la merda da te mi chiamo
impanato non so perché era che non fate
domande allora che bello messaggio mica
me lo ricordavo così bella allora allora
signori la prima cosa che facciamo
andare sulla macchina sa che alla radice
a china su uno solo io sono io che in un
uccidermi ciao avete un tizio e poi
ucciderlo sono io
dietro questa casa diciamo tra canone
aggiuntivo significava fare basta deve
mai avete lo vedo comunque perché jason
chassey così per un attimo ho sentito la
musichetta di terrore mi sono calato
solo io
ho capito che sei tu non vengo da te
fammi capire dove l'altro di queste
cuore ti senti mai funziona l'olio no no
prossi casa ma non ti funziona proprio
no no perché devo ridurre per odiarlo ma
dietro questa casamento morituri capire
cessario quel rumore del caso ha capito
dall altra gente
aspettami e del tenente abbiamo qua
vediamo se c'è qualcuno qua sono io qui
non si tratta di una macchina nuova
primavera nella macchina
eccoli pensi di merda livello livelli
vedo alcune nella foresta perché anno fa
ancora correre porca vacca sai cosa devo
mettere le trappole le trappole sulla
macchina che mi chiamandole mettono gli
altri allora che lanceremo hanno verso
la bellissima messo dove è possibile
veramente dove quello che ha ammazzato
il proprio bagno la crono ma perché
maitreya è perché ha capito le dita
l'aiuta a me hanno fatto benissimo messi
i moniti per lui sono tutti quanti in
grado ma io sto attaccando ma sono tutti
stati perché non lo so ninja tv saranno
una mano bravo niger non ti ammazza te
uno che sta ammazzatutti se compagni per
faranno fuori prima boy è questa la
macchina ce n'è una quella che va dentro
shifty da baseball chiuso un libro the
dr agire con l'a1 in moto tipo di buco
d'accordo anche perché ci sono gli
uomini sono più di seto questo figo
allora è la batteria anzitutto r no
perché non la mente dell'ok ma la messa
dalla parte sbagliata giudice di 40
juliet e il caldo fuori genitori quale
quella cavo ha capito fa bene te le
trappole iniziano ciao
questo è quello che giocavano a marco
presta ad una mano due vi è quello buono
si vero piccolo
buona che tanto arriva gente salve
buongiorno con cui stiamo tutto bene
tutto bene
che cazzo fai tu a lesbico che cazzo è
pronto per quel lui star domenica malato
perché non lo vengo in pieno l'altro che
cazzo succede che pagò a caso come è ora
ho portato dentro a casa perché non
butta dentro casa ciao zio allora non è
che se david ha in mano vuol dire che
non ti ammazzo rimangono però rimane
solo lui ma dai casa sono gesso nella
partita più corta della vita ma come ho
sbagliato ho fatto nero ma non devo fare
quando sono gente nella partita fi corta
dell'universo non è possibile ancora in
casa quando vedo non sento non c'era
stato mai utilizzato soltanto la mazza
di lega ammasso equa ma come mai la
gente nella cabina strabilia straniero m
vedove ciao zio ragazzo ma quando sei
scalzo vicine volte non ci sono la botta
nei cd come 0 su 7
come solo se si vuol dire se la massa di
voti lunga però erano vincenzo non è
ovvio che ci hanno messo dalla partita
più lampo di di venerdì 3 chic di
sinistra vice ti fa schifo
c'è una realtà in maniera nessuno
uno schifo raga stato mi è piaciuto
tantissimo stato proprio bello 528
puliti xp sono bravo a fare jazz ma come
07 mazzetti 21 era lui che luccica
l'altro gli ha spaccato la testa sulla
porta sulla cosa sola volta ma perché
sono usciti dalla partita capito quindi
non me le dà come kill però mi
raccontate con cui i prezzi di merda
nome l'età comunque solo bianco e
vedendo me lo insegna la fina però metà
è sì se non grazie al caso nessun gelo
farebbe mai punti anche va bene c'è chi
in session centrato no
porca vacca rispetta chimenti si cercano
scaricano da chi lo sta caricando
cassonati sta entrando lampadine ma
perché i believe no sei buono fi detto
brady e non degni vedi notissimo non sei
capace quando è capito lei è stato
bellissimo perché non sarà perché sono
offline che per allora come si fa quando
mi ha detto parti
no ho sbagliato evitato un'altra persona
ma come beh vi sbagliate periodi non
pagati più così ma non devo rifare se
casini io marley bagarre mino raiola
tu che voglia sempre le cose magari cosi
non basta in jason e soprattutto cazzo
sempre chiesa sono fatemi fi
prima dobbiamo il cazzo per essere jason
adesso non per caso per se una persona
normale
note case che si accesero provvede a
prato manola perché ora che sembra
personaggi disastrosa o fai tu il party
in vita mia ho pensato che il party
faccio io
vai ma sanno che si parli così perché la
sta giocando tanto lo fa
che palle sono intanto la prima cosa
abbiamo fatto e la per scaldarsi e la
prima vinta veloce così conseguente
forse questa è una giusta o fire è di
fare di subito carmela portiamo ma sai
che puoi portare le mappe credo hanno
poi vota c'è un modo per votarle se non
sbaglio non so come torce ragazzi
ah che bello era di 13 tornati così
subito con una botta di vita
chissà se riusciamo a fare una live dal
giappone mentre che va bene agli
infelici sarah sarebbe fighissimo per sé
non possiamo infatti però sarebbe figo
farla sicuro che non voleva saperne
sì basta chiederlo per andare a prendere
da bere arriva primo arrivo dal mio
corso subito
stiamo per partire occhio no grazie
no grazie
lauren se è ancora jason te lo giuro
vieni qua non è vero per questo cosa
sono i costi di frutta perché sono pigro
non riesco a spulciare la punta certi
esco ma ciò che penso quindi che si
faccia un po esalto quindi mani avanti
così
è ben accetta ma non sai cosa
6 torino non sono né io né né pietro
ragazzi quindi dobbiamo fare dobbiamo
fare un po perché sei tu sono qua o se
qualcuno ha dei consigli visto che
facciamo comunque pagare a questo gioco
dateci consigli questo ha chiuso le
porte aperte perfetto vieni 26 in una
casa di fianco al falò vieni questa
accende la radio max cerrai i problemi
allora ho scoperto che per far partire
la polizia
devi di commettere la batteria di
entrare o leggere per far partire la
polizia a partire con la campana polizia
anche ma che siano ha chiamato la sera
marco che devo farla partire con un
fucile o il gesto non ricorda cosa di
preciso dai le chiavi delle elezioni la
macchina e chiavi non c'è stata sperando
però la materia
io sono in ballo c'e la macchina ma
nonno però non so però in un unico solo
a questa partita sarà un buona merda
solo sono convinto perché è da una vita
che ha un gioco come villa ger pil
quindi pm per il culo ma mai non so come
si chiama la speranza come stronza la
vita in un giocone stronzo quindi a
riferirlo
ma il 6 no no no è neanch'io sai ma zero
come niente
la valigetta che bel niente ho chiuso
non c'è nulla
c'è poi dentro niente mi sa che ci sono
vicino perché sento già l'audio bello
forte sono le figure non dominerà chi
sta andando da jason con villa e strano
strano anzi che potrebbe rizzo poi se
primis e non correva al trotto cosenza
insieme al tratto lo sapevo io non ho
mai dirlo queste cose o che cazzo fa
questo chiudi chiudi grida porta serra
bravo a uscire io esco
si sfonda la porta a gironi e di tutta
la finestra il volto ed è meglio non lo
so ma mi sono cagato addosso forte sto
aspettando che non lascerà stata mi
sarei buttato giù fortissimo di
sull'inflazione
salve signora bella grazie di essere
venuto a farmi compagnia soprattutto di
avermi avvertito che c'era gente perché
sono ci aiutano e curiosa riuscito di
brutto si infilò in aprilia
la polizia ne aspetta a sinistra oa
destra non lo sa mai nella vita lo so ma
credo a destra l'ultima volta era destra
questa destra che ti ricordi che ci
aveva preso nel culo non abbiamo le sale
come italiano prove quindi erano date si
sta poi abbiamo fatto tutto il percorso
prendere la destra qui a destra
noi siamo a sinistra quindi il perfetto
come si esce la sostanza e mi hanno dato
sei tu grande affetto per i bastard
estrae live aid brutta stronza colli e
sci e sci e sci che già sta dall'altra
parte fi ora dobbiamo dare a destra
quindi qui posso mettere i segnali nino
rota non superassero bellissimo ok di
qua di bari per i papà non so dove la
polizia ma credo che sia di qua perché
questa mi segue maggio caprica situati
cosa vuoi
ora mi fermo a schermo anche le
strumenti sapevo io ma che hai messo il
follo 6 il tasto follow dei videogiochi
tipo che seguì la sua personalità
che cazzo guardava anche le mie stesse
curve ma ciò che mangiare da solo e cosa
vuole e lesbica guarda senso e se devo
vincere york e sul gioco bene dei vince
anche lei che non sa fare un cazzo però
mi sento
ecco una male sarà andata giorno anche
se la polizia sinistra mi piace al
similarmente serba utilizzata dal mio
incolpino forte posso sia la sinistra
sia anche perché mi do da solo ma in
tutto questo gesù dome è il mosso destro
abbiamo la miniera non mi sta piacendo
e allora la porta montagna cui la mappa
io neanche qui ho una chiave inglese in
mare basta mischia fa che vinciamo
sarebbero due di fila vinta nella vita
dice un record allora io sono arrivato
ma sai che secondo me non è mai qua la
polizia
qua dovrebbe essere come non possiamo
dell'avanti nei soliti sospetti spetta
in una tecnica quella sinistra deve
darmi coppino altri di ossigeno destra
che è obesa strozzi ne vale dal re
sinistra line da coach avessi visto dai
vari usi per cretini finire dove mafai
dalla parte opposta almeno ma la berlina
caprari ma corre pure corre pure cattina
posto madonna rischiato perché vecchi
bastano appiccicata aprì la mappa
no non c'è niente perciò deve starmi
appiccicata al culo ma che bravi ma
megan a buy dell'altro albero madonna
che fastidio
qui stanno vicini proprio video poi poi
mi che avessi tali fucsia che mi chiama
vediamo km
che palle by apple suo recente
almeno che non è qui dove sei tu a
sinistra badanti mattina [__] s'è
sentito l'effetto sonoro bruttissimo ma
è a sinistra è sicuro perché sento
effetti sonori qua e là sotto non era
guarda che io io so già come andrà a
finire che li sopravvive io no a lei mi
sta seguendo per un giro che sarebbe si
guarda che bella ma io ci ho provato a
cettina apposta con la pancia pisa di
cazzo successo che io avevo una torcia
attiva con un [__] bravo ma non ci
vedrà mai non ci vedrà mai e gestione
rilievi e lì davanti alla polizia
malizia city zitto zitto che lo vedo ma
non si vedeva tanta 5 a 5 la non ci ha
visti mi piace si muove questa quanto
l'ammazzo si ferma stamattina ma non ci
ha visto sta coprendo la zona forse
abbiamo azzeccato per la polizia perché
sta come siete trasportato in mezzo alla
via
d'altra parte e dall'altra parte è
andato dalla parte a passare sei tu qua
merda era tassista attenzione ai
commercianti che non ti vede perché io
avevo lasciato hama visto 40 secondi
raga mi caga siamo e siete natura in
casa faccio io non sei ecco qui si ferma
si spiegano non ti vede mi ha visto e ha
visto che ho già un miracolo non ti
muovere per l'amor di gesù cristo stai
ferma ferma cosa non capisce di star che
deve stare ferma no velocità preso jason
se no ti ha ucciso poter esistere 10
secondi di più che arriva la polizia ma
la va o la spacca va in aiuto
aiutateci i secondi secondo me se noi se
dall'altra
parte video ecco le quali la tua pagina
3 2 1 se non è che abbiamo perso più
bravo bravo
mica mi ha schierato un coltello ha
mancato è stato bellissimo
niente lemper sera [__] olio al 50
per cento faccio veramente cagare a
spruzzo non c'è verso hai un premio tony
che cazzo è chi ha ammazzato il mio
amico abbassato il mio libro che tengono
solo quindi s trova mente amico si è
accovacciato che mi vede non dovrebbe
vedermi donna che caga ancora di che
gira jason posso in teoria ancora
vincere però ecco cork col demonio
vabbè dai ragazzi dai perché ma perché
ora incredibile ma marjah una volta è
successo al 50 per cento annuncia 0 che
sfiga di ernst dai però mi che non possa
essere resi sfigato credete alla gente
in lion è chi sta bene sono convinto e
tanto è così ma porca vacca
vabbè tanto sappiamo che sai come sono
lo so che se non lo so porca vacca
abbraccio alla fine escono trojan di
dietro ma con quella sbagliata 20 aiuto
è come quando esco
106 per cento cioè la vista sicuramente
la vista al momento è realizzato il
personaggio via ora gli occhi adesso vai
tranquillo non ho capito si sta
spaccando questa porta aiuto cazzo non
posso provare a correre fino a qua dagli
altri bastardi guarda dove sono
mentre io mi distraggo sto stronzo gli
altri sono alla polizia come si parla a
jason de merda gli altri sono la polizia
jayson di advertiser at the police staff
following piece of shit avrà capito no
di oderica e vabbè alla tua madre
[__] guarda verso stucchi ha pure dai
di other guys time out e polizia
ok guai to you follow me ayew retarded
cose debolissimo cazzo vuoi da me a
lesbico che chiazza successa è stato
bellissimo
che cazzo successo no così non ci voglio
credere
non ci fosse ok no ma non è successo
veramente non so non sta succedendo sta
roba dice la polizia
io sono la fresca sarà la nostra fatto
c'è l'inter in teoria dovrei arrivare
tipo in queste case qui e fermarmi un
attimo per sperare che ritorni in
tabella
adesso più che mai e di altri testa
sempre la polizia non follow me down a
capitan america però è stato bellissimo
è stato troppo bello vederlo sparire
stato troppo vero è la madonna quanta
violenza ma quanto quanto è stata cosa
più senza senso chi abbia mai visto
quanto
ma perché ero l'ultimo a beh allora ero
l'unica ragazza a casa nemmeno vicino
vabbè altra questo parma salute ho preso
degli cosi dei bonus che non sapevo ci
fossero vabbè vabbè qui si esce ma file
il big match è meno un po al divo era
riuscito citato bisogna fare arriverebbe
da bono e mi sa che è perché la riffa
con quella di prima infatti meglio non
perdere la coda raga che cazzo
ma si sta a sentire cosa ho preso di si
sta sentendo nicchia scusatemi racca che
non si usa l'audio all'attivo nove c'è
io non so che cazzo dire forse una delle
cose più non sense che sia mai successo
da quando gioco cioè non mi era mai
successo di convincere uno veramente a
lasciarmi perdere o poi con chi inglese
il tuo savona ha capito di quello che
gli ho detto non avrà capito niente che
scaccia nero così brando poi vinciamo
si è basta perdere la prima ho vinto io
la prima la seconda quasi dai racconterà
come vittoria per 55 a me cannato è
riuscita alla polizia o sfortuna però
avuto una bella idea di quella di
mandarlo via quindi è quasi una vittoria
per me
ma gesù
comunque io ancora nonostante abbia
ormai cantone di gioco
8 adesso volpe giorno di più si è pagato
per sicuro non è possibile comunque ciò
difensore di gioco ancora non capito con
che criterio scegli jesini sto tizio non
ho capito non è a caso perché cioè le
preferenze volendo no se lo stato siamo
noi
ho visto nina no non siamo dove dove
dove sei
e che ne so io in una casa fra streaming
su domeniche c'è la macchina qua a
boston qui
ok io cerco subito labate vedi di
trovare dei pezzi della macchina che una
volta voglio scappare non sono mai
scappati in macchina guidando io voi che
avete che mi sembra bravo bravo a
deviare le chiavi ce l'abbiamo bene come
i due chiavi a posto senza chiari e poi
partire con la macchina nord quei cavi
no no
a mali estremi estremi macchine mantero
giro tre cose trovato la chiave il lo
spray e il coltellino svizzero lo spray
e voti il coltellino svizzero ancora non
capita pensare che forse per le spinge
fino a quando i molti tutti prende credi
nicodemo svizzero e voti di presentare a
mente libera
ok atti libera proprio subito famsi cosa
che li premere il tasto al contenuto si
sono che sarebbe ok non è equipaggiata
ho trovato domini jarvis questa rabbia
quella tipo tu parli e tutti quelli che
una radio non vengono sentiti da jason
quando quando mi chiama come sapessero
mercanzia enciclopedia di sto gioco mi
armo io batto bravo così che formare il
miglior verminaio che mangiare patatine
nella live
comunque ho trovato un cazzo di ora per
la marca
aveva usato una pistola razzi che
qualcosa spero ma speriamo che sia un
buon a busto jason mai che incontriamo
un genio che non è capace a giocare
chiama galli romagna ricorda un tubo
coltellino e ma non ero messo messo
invece la macchina quale macchina sono a
e non so non c'è la mappa è adesso no
lasciato il coltellino [__] prende
prendiamo è che non lo possa sostituire
ai e cosi pure chiavi so anch'io eh no
c'erano i sacramenti servirà tantissimi
tavoli perché io qua mori per la memoria
tennessee
porca vacca adottare il coltellino per
terra vero o non troviamo mai un cazzo
trovo le stesse cose insieme mikamai na
roba direzione sei tu quale macchina ma
hanno hanno messo qualcosa no ogni caso
non pagato in mano porca vacca mi urlare
per scappare questa casa c'è una lucia
draka
nole a questo momento bruttissimo sapevo
come sei morto è con simon e colesterolo
alto tra svezia e con il colesterolo
troppe troppe schifezza mujer pizza
rimaniamo qui porca put a mi spavento è
[Musica]
ma dove lo state facendo di preciso se
ci sono più fuori anche per jason e qui
fuori cerca di fare una roba lecce all
ciavatta quanto a cagà quanta caga in
questo gioco occhio che ti carica ti
carica di carica sicuro noti carica ma
c'è la porta aperta forza il culo di con
articolo ma serali perché stai fermo li
usa le tue tattiche amico fagone voi
come fatto in sé ma perché io credo nei
rack ulivi bar
ok fu turno madonna che caga veramente
salve file a roma fi è bravo non così
aver meno lo senti si avvicina proprio
mentre è già spaventato ma non come
adesso una frase che poi non corre tram
penati sta caricando
non lo vedo che non ci sono tre vivo
come ucciso se c'era un altro vicino è
secco dietro che faccia ti posso ma come
commessa per il lasco tecco per il
nostro cane di consigli tiger woods
all'inizio di un grande e fare buca in
uno va peggio che ci siamo spacchiamo
esaltato il match è stato bellissimo
molto profondo questo match siti di vero
placido record per testare fare ei
gemelli negli intermezzi che c'è
qualcosa a faccia fatti vedere come si è
distrutto da questa sessione di di
scappa scappa da jason scappata giorno
jason comunque ragazzo aspettative prima
di un gameplay ma che poi le nostre
dell'esn espresse nel placement a tanto
sono le patatine i fan
adesso adesso guardate regalati dei fan
ragiono io non faccio anche via spesa
tramite l aspetto è stata la madre ti ho
detto le patatine che vale gameplay è no
entrano nella leva dei problemi di
linate di connessione a me va bene
facciamo un paio di tentativi
i non sono anche se si vede l'over
leghisti min live si no studi giocando
più premi gioco quindi la gente vede che
entri nel mio gruppo a caso a parte so
che c'è il mio faccione non c'è neanche
niente
stiamo aspettando di iniziare una nuova
partita in questo momento siamo nel
match making stavo guardando se vado a
dare come si per salutarmi quali
problemi non lo voglio andava bastano
già bevuto dall'ara ballini prima
bastava la voglia mangia la sintesi di
forma ma chissà che la questa divertente
che io porca vacca da questo divertente
che io ho chiamato questa live jazz non
la prende nel didietro ed ero io a jason
all'inizio ok io l'ho chiamata proprio
gesto non la prende nel didietro e io
ero io ero jason quindi la casa è
fantastica la lascia la lascerò così nel
titolo perché per farmi onore ma il play
cominciamo a sua volta si sentì entra
ora se gesù cristo rechi come si mette
aiuto lo sai cucino next per mangiare
no mi sia fatto tutto
angelino alfano a 180 sdrai carlo è il
10 ne occhiata tirata sono abituato ma
ci credo che sei mio fisso del ginocchio
atteso sulla scrivania o era quello che
mi sono fatto a livigno gradendo noi è
questa perché non mi vien dato via lo
chiamo così c'è un signore è la chapelle
des ti ho visto quanta bella società non
mi piace vedi che ho comprato apposta
stagione
mica per jason calcio a noi all'estero
compreso il pesto e secondo me è sceso
nel primo questo che il pronuncia sono
le serie che ci niente e può essere o
giapponese ma quello di sake perché
diventa velato reano questo è il coreano
sarà già prima dei simboli un po strano
non so niente si ricordava sushi
esatto dopo mangiato suicidio ma
discutiamo tranquillamente dei cazzi
nostri quanto siamo mica in largo con
30.000 persone
forse sono gli arresti per morire no
basta mai e paga e basta basta stato da
marzo cos'è cos'è ma sei coltelli questa
casa nessuno che me lo dice in live
ragazzi mi chiedo ma aiutate poi posso
aspettare la luminosità che mi chiama
pedone o un tronco una gamba
apri la madonna quanto spetta aiuto si è
agitato come fate cazzo che volete
sì strumentata luminosità o una padella
allora belle personne sai che ho trovato
un coltello di quelli che puoi lanciare
io non sapevo che fossero in casa sì ma
non so di me grande amico e dovette
quali alla macchina avevano aprì allora
io sono stato spiato
riceviamo in griglia e lo faccio perché
sono tuo amico casi e credo nel cuore
delle carte beh provate a prenderla sta
macchina se ci riuscite
allora faccio questa roba da quando me
lo hanno fatto a me
porca vamente le trappole di fianco alla
macchina esserci di meglio ed a pezzi di
merda se però l'hanno fatta adesso vi
curate
allora dove sono tutti sti stronzi ho
capito chi sta al sonno
eccoli qua giusto ciò seccato se cercate
eccoli mai si stronzi ciao un giorno mi
scappi la portano alla tellina vale ora
posso parlare di tagli caso mi senta non
fosse successo
siete che non vedo dove sta riuscendo
l'altro finestrella addio bravo arrivo
arrivo e ai tre in basso a sinistra una
mappa e allora sì sì ma io sono già qua
ecco che cazzo mi prendi b6 tripla dr
dall'altra parte sta rientrando in casa
la sardo è fino in fondo ci sei a quando
in casa la casa diventa rossa ciao zio
piegata non sapeva sta roba da riesce
tranquillamente chic lisa verbo metà in
prova a fare una roba decente
vediamo se riesce che riesca a far star
osa tac con la trappola
se ne scappa la sono un genio ne
parliamo di gente non ho sbagliato tasto
[__] vacca e ancora classica qua è
volevi ciao zio acquistato posto in
effetti è a parlare noi due io ammazzo
la gente però vi lo faccio bella figura
e polmoni sono ancora qua gli altri da
milano ti ammazzo
la minaccia più forte sul ponte quando
caso l'ha travolta del ponte è vero e
proprio
[Musica]
ecco la famiglia subito ma la città ha
fatto dietro front
ma tra la quanto scarso quanto scalzo
questo arcavacata è infilato il
coltellino svizzero non vale pezzo di
merda dove che doverle dove saranno al
colore amica se sono stonato non posso
anche trasportarmi quanto torneo minchia
c'è una corsa devastante lo zio anche
hanno corso un ora
dove vai se non partono ma non aver
suscitato ma portato dove sono gli altri
il genio aiuto ricordare che posso
lanciare cose noi oi opporremo tutti
come si lasciano i coltelli lo sai
al 34 ammazzo tempo sono qua dentro la
fico è certo che adesso arrivato basso
potete ascoltare stata sara conoscendolo
so io stalking a biblet cafè stock ce ne
sono io
mica che palle quanti sono tipo dentro
vedrai
ma cosa fa questa e sheva è quella
cinese zhao cinese
alla prossima mi ammazzo tutti così poi
si mette d'imposta tipo le modelle però
niente così sta cagando in mano
fortissimo il fatto che le 6 si sfonda
la porta di merda sfondato 3 eccola la
zia no
la mancata che deficente bravo dire
stalker che sarebbe tipo inseguire e ma
non non capisco cosa mi cambia quindi
che che parla mentre la testa casa vabbè
tanto di sfondo questa porta oltre che
il deretano una cosa la riuscita già
bella mente
sapete niente non ho capito cosa stava
il più duro tranquilla che sia riuscita
vi ricordiamo ora vuoi corner
ora che caga a jean razzo però c'è un
lato c'è la zona
store chissà quando sei dietro qualcuno
mi chiama non può correre per sempre
[Musica]
oddio ho preso toni jarvis era la cinese
di prima fa passato primi jarvis invece
di lei
no mi ha stanato agronoma stanato penso
che sia stato dove fossero per congelato
la finestra giro per casa mia la
finestra ma si trattano così compagni
maledetto sia rispettoso ma tu te ne
stai tranquillo ma tu dove sei
io sono tranquillo non ci sono ne uccide
uccisi tre americhe sono usciti a
modesto quelli stanno uscendo tra le
pieghe stato libero allora qua quella
pensa di potermi far fuori con la cosa
razzi ma che deficente lo stai facendo
lo stop driblando perché non mi sparerà
per sun armino fatto
puoi sognare ora non so se abbia questo
è un [__] deficienza no
la pagherai prodotta pucci de rege dono
così si può c'è un mol e quando c'è
altro giorno tipo di vino di corsi fate
qualcosa per chi ricerca una accetta
quella che aveva lui e in più una donna
di indossare il migliore della madre di
jason che si trova nella crisi genera
iniziale ecco che faceva la card america
che fortuna cavi posti aiuto che
contenga posto
porca vacca infame laida guardalinee
riusciti a scappare o maledetti perché
quella mi ha sparato razzi in faccia se
non la minchia allora questa di messia
macchine o ai brutti fani non credo
perché è la pole a dai dati su questo
caso è la macchina non ce n'è mai non ci
dona le frutta trojan ovvio ma dovremo
subito uno svizzero
un pezzo di merda cazzo sono tech
sapevo che era arrivata la polizia
marty giorno non avevo idea guarda
quello che ci prova a non sapevo fosse
arrivata la polizia te lo giuro ma dai
tutta rava come si lanciano i coltelli
così a celico tempo non ci posso credere
rilanciare coltellino e ricondurle
arriva nel 2000 arrivano l'avvocato per
niente regole andata al keniano 2 è
invece la serata sono stati di
provenienza
d'altra parte le azioni di terra sono
entrambi e tra anche a una fucina fucino
ma perché non esca premiazione varia dai
ragazzi tra le uscite o se si erano
infatti quello là quello che lascia i
scasso con una merda scarso nemmeno
l'altra non sono vicende note ricorso a
prenderlo sono dire live antiquariato
vinto comunque anche se no mi colpivano
mentre gli spari però non è una novità
ei berom il caso non per le marano vinto
sono lì e non la musica siccome con
indosso per il bosso quello col lavoro
velocissimo all'aspire dolcissimo
prodotto figlio di [__] meno le
prende per il culo
mai fatto così uno è morto l'altro non
penso perché non perché se viene a
madonna questo cioè orbite cazzuti si
merita merita ma se mi sei piaciuta va
bene devo superare il tasto per questo
gioco già non vinci mai ci manca solo
che è che una facile faccia cazzo che
vuoi ma ancora non è finito o chrome è
ancora un capitolo non come no era
quella di prima e che cos'è la politica
è 4 su 7 calzare dovrà essere sopra la
tipa di adesso che sono meritava l'altro
è la scarsa o maritato di morire two
dove ha cliccato e qualche anno però io
non sapevo che jason non poteva sei
pronto a tutto
ma sapevo che gesù non vede la polizia
l'avete solo quando arriva e fanti per
questo continuiamo sono qua perché
facendo altro bastarda
vabbè io direi facciamo una player vasta
come una preda
vediamo qua e stato bello è stato bello
la tipa se le merita duramente a simone
montanari vera l'altro no ai fatti è
morto l'altro aveva preso per il culo
che non è andato alla fine poteva
vincere lui poi ha fatto un culo così
domani 6 marzo credeva che era un
deficiente tra una tipa sommitali non ha
fatto che il terzo che ha vinto per 2 la
tipa ecco una delle mai questo beach
vero no mancano 4 minuti
ac aggiornamento vabbè dai nei 39 minuti
e mezzo e il meglio gangi e mentre
provava aspettare
sono entrato set gruppo di classe
unboxing e nome perché non ne mettono al
3 maggio verso l'open wall e mettono più
sono queste minchia se mi fai sprecare
tutti quanti ma comprende con tre o
quattro ma quali quelli palestra adamo
reti in 77 a questa di più ma serve da
chiave la 250 per aprire il giovane
compri tre o quattro perché poi salgono
di prezzo che dice mi credi maniera
migliore no e allora la fan culo e
monteleone un primo e stimano buone
venivano tolti comporti potrà 4 rifili
conviene aspettare
una settimana prima e 4200 è un prende
col numerino tantissimo questo capita
aiuto aiuto mai perché comunque le
migliori
bye bye bye o per possa trovare questa
roba non 800 euro a te lo giuro si scemo
sì la donna non è proprio da donna stava
come 800 logico che sia ma io avevo
altro giuro perché dovrei spendere 800
euro per che recitano che l'ha comprata
per 800 euro
ma perché magari ne son su blu per
parlare
wow veramente le scarpe blu ma queste
sembrano damerino vero che hanno il
bordino bluetooth che se non abbiamo
capito ma per questa merda lo aspetta e
allora quanto costa 800 euro
se qualcosa dovrebbe spendere 800 euro
guardate 800
compriamo né castro che una volta 100
euro compriamo una gonnellina in gioco
chissà se usciva madonna s l'ex vice
preghiamo tutti i punti che sanno farlo
se non passando da mentana
basta avere ultima lei l'ultima l'ho
preso la gonnellina aprì e non apre
bello che sarà importante pompei sta già
con si trova a cazzo sei un nome come si
portano delle secchiate premuto per
sentieri lati ha premuto che appoggiano
rimane aperta
grazie
allupato h manca un minuto 39 da allora
no no no ma io sono un po di tutto
non solo anno tutto sei pagato si sono
fi pausa bene mi piace un aggiornamento
della madonna
niente solo farebbe facciamo una sola
[__] solo che cazzo sono ancora
spesso no va bene ha ripreso manca un
minuto
se vuoi king of the kill quello è un
altro gioco
hai sbagliato gioco ma ve la facciamo
una patellina matching fail ed anche se
guardando il gioco sbagliato è un
farmaco molto mutata
analizzavano so se posso facendo
streaming solo vista roba se solo le
spese mente di sta roba
non so perché è un gioco ma di contino
c'era un non dorme del minore potere
quando
comunque tanto io succo è sempre quando
c'è questa roba
il live quindi va bene abbiamo fatto
l'ora di venerdì 13 raga che non è
andata male ma la fatica per una volta
la vita facciamo string dove vinco due
volte le volte c'è qualche tacca lascia
stare
dai facciamo nè un atleta midi indirizza
mi però mi chiamerà infinito va beh
vediamo se duro falcone facciamo un
altro punto ne faccio
dami supporto morale amico va bene il
supporto il morale ma che ca pelliccia
questo bouquet tu vedi liberamente che
c'è gente in giro magari con la
gonnellina e quella collina va da 800
euro
sì anche problemi altro
profeta che starà preparando
è
ma dei militari dai faccio la
la giornata della vita tanto per voglio
morire subito quindi proviamoci allagava
dei militari face che il punto dove si
concentra maggior parte della gente
infatti ecco guardali stormo di piccioni
sì però quasi finito quindi
tanto entra
un po
non ne sono convintissimo che supero
come lo schifo perché non gioco da una
vita e mezza sai con chi gioca
tantissimo da solo triste tipo che
adesso l editing in live ragazzi ora
cavalca ecco c'erano già subito subito
va così contro pam le botte in bocca ai
a rimasto lì non ci crede lui non riesce
a scavalcare il muretto e stupido aiuto
stammi lontano a lesbica no non ci credo
da qualcuno genova bresciano dietro
subito aveva 88 conferma ma dai ma in
partite hai visto che però fatto uno e
ucciso quindi non è andata troppo male e
possiamo giocare insieme
tutto calcolato tutto calcolato che a
quanto già tutto ci sei
2 nomina online si lamenti se adesso non
più prima a scendere so che cosa ci
mancherà ma di vita che bello che sei
croazia evento bello forte bello figo
invitational ci sono i tornei di
organico che vi fa del fratello di
stermini thomas organizzatori italiani
manon e vince una gonnellina esatto di
circa
ma la gonna enel se c'è qualcuno che
cialone lino ovviamente no perché se pro
sotto 100 euro sarà lara il cazzo grado
ci vediamo girare guarda invece con un
nero capelli apre con la gonnellina sì
esatto ma poi mette anche da uomo
boh spero family friendly
6 ecco che allora ciao amico bello forte
poi si fanno le moto e magie magico al
tf 4 ma contro la f1 cosa no al t1
spinge a sabato nella galleria cos'è
cioè provate che magari vi si è stampata
la live cosa valiamo dai una facciamone
una sola ma serie a o raga ci proviamo e
non so come viene perché tanto il live
però menadito le dice andato bene quindi
possiamo permetterci di far pagare
antimo venezia
per queste venezia è la puglia come
venezia
ho parlato lui canale da feto
ma che bene
queste mi aveva ragione vai aspetta ma
che aspetta allora vai venezia trecase
un po d'acqua e venezia cannes roma la
chiave la vera torino quando c'è la
passione torino quando più di quanto
tale è così che quella città che con il
13 30 venezia la chiami solo tu venezia
la chiamo la differenza come ti è venuto
city è venuto è una città come l'acqua
venisse a casa pervasivi questa
terminologia accusato roma è questa di
fianco a quella europea domenica roma
che un'altra milano 39 milano dov'è
eccola eccola tutti gli uffici collega
danese kasper hannibal e aisha frega
allora ecco che cosa c'è una roba su col
tetto strana no è un graffito non è roba
per lui non capivo ma occhio che c'era
c'è gente e poi a venezia è vero è un
alterato di dietro la provincia amica
orbo un soffio
ora facciamo un bacio a quanto dura
moriamo subito sticazzi a come la nostra
è una figurina però più importante come
compito questi dello studio lo sento
dovevo grattarmi fortissimo quindi ogni
tanto l'amica red bull puntato il fucile
fantoni jarvis occhio
la tecnica la tanica la saremar dai è un
gioco sbagliato grado gioco adesso la
batteria
migliora il mondo sono potuti giu di
chiavi
[Musica]
pesarsi trovando cecchino no figura
cecchino ancora non ha capito
non so se c'è qualcuno e mi pare di sì
ho visto uno cade la prima tv ninì ha
avuto lì dove c'è il simbolo di serial
power la si può dire si guarda papà che
venezia va bene si posero paolo cioè non
va bene in questo vennero bene come noi
sei alibi che sei sta cercando un
sentimento e mangiato tu sei mangiato
messa ciao nonna sono successe sono
degli hunger games si provi mangiato
nella prima che si sono un po di hunger
games si non troverei un accesso al
gioco tipo gli hunger games ce n'era una
si chiamava mi ricordo mai il nome a sei
tu che corre v.madonna miglia che
capisci pescato suo pezzo che poi salire
dalla scala dal balcone sempre stato in
questa
hanno giocato troppo questo è vero in
questa città sempre stato michele guarda
la madonna sapevo mai sta roba ma
manninger che ci sono nuovi i graffiti
hanno fatto una pagina pericolo marche
graffiti almeno almeno quelli sonori
cento spari una storia che stai sempre
attento a quello che dice certo di gesù
sono io sopra il tetto ai caricando un
qualcosa caricato no era una volta che
io ho sentito un proiettile cadere
proietti
giornata durante la giornata
la grande la tua no cretino da kakà che
hai fatto a capire perché sta vendendo
volevo farti non è vero è per tu con la
quadra no non credo c'è gente è a
vincere un amore così bella che a
venezia simpatica
ma
[Musica]
aperta aperto aperto
maria via via di pavia di cose rozzo ma
che non c'è gente robot che sicuramente
è o no amica il bombardamento porca
vacca in family ed avere chiare possiamo
facilmente può certo esce da sali mica
che si visibilissimo non averlo stelle
certo andiamo vini come nemica ha detto
se qualcuno di vita dietro arrivo un po
e non è il massimo passare in mezzo alla
strada in questo momento il mio cuore
occhio che ci stanno per bombardare
lavoriamo perché un bombardamento in
live è impossibile abbiamo mai morti con
button ed il laico profitto la live
porterà cento del gioco è morto un uomo
fondamento anzi due trecento ore sta
ripensando a jason di prima che lo ha
convinto a grande macchina a capri
bye bye venezia stanno bombardando
venisse
poi c'è la macchina sembra che già scusa
ripeto proceda macchinista non ho capito
la macchina ho visto che la macchina
mousse 16
ma è già aiutato ma sì
allora vediamo di fare un attimo il
punto della situazione gente simpatica e
visto quanto questa non mi serve per il
mio vero niente
e evidente però la macchina andiamo a
[__] che andiamo cioè un back tor ti
serve
noi ci rendiamo un altra volta no
vediamo [__] se è bravo è bravo sei
già partito bene io dietro fa il
tassista che dio tassista allora andiamo
dove come rigenerazione passato cosa ho
passato le ere passate tipo così a
destra quindi dovremmo andare tipo agli
assi gnani a poljana quali sono
ho capito mandrake e no design
si fermi
vai vai vai
[Musica]
rivolti a perdere qua pensavo mi sembra
una cosa bruttissima allora seguitare a
guidare io la patente a meno
però the ballet
sì è una fan non mi pare
perciò pugliese che mia mamma lo sai che
mi ama ancora scuola guida tipo dati può
regalare la patente e la faccia ma si
fanno mescole dure lamenterò però mi
piaccia ad offrire
milano
vedi che serviva la tanica che quella
stessa macchina di venerdì 13 euro che
ci fa pensare è la stessa che ripaghi il
benzinaio valenti aggiuntivi file o
fermati bye bye torneo che forse ho
visto un arma forse
sono stato anche visto armi qua per te
31 ha detto manzato che sembra di aver
visto armi [__] ha detto no hai trovato
gli agnelli le palle
la moto si chiama parla il mondo dove la
moto va bene quindi torna guarda un
agente un fazzoletto
eccoli
oggi i test
allora ho detto l'ultimo giro sportivo
giro però si è però sì c'è però sì
[Musica]
l'ultimo giro lorenzo davanti rossi
dietro è deciso di fare non mi capitò a
c'è un buggy quindi occhio che c'è gente
a non hai qualche già forse nuccioni sul
sicuro fermati non si ferma non si pecca
ma posso peggiore per la moto non c'era
vabbè mcdonald è il mio
la prima lezione riusciamo a trovare un
[__] cecchino prima della fine
partita ho visto neanche per sbaglio
ok nicchia o figurazione trovo mese ma
non potremo mai ricerca vattene da una
vittoria non gioco come sono ottimista
quando già questi giorni effettivamente
bisogna solo attivisti cechi spariamo il
culo due volte a tutti i due volte ombre
quattro simboli ne stiamo attivando
appena era 99 aia cav
se in casa per 4 h e boogie sulla gamba
però siamo in una posizione abbastanza
buona questo devo dire la cappa io lo
odio
dovete non riesco a separare il lago per
otto veramente ti butto giù per 4 1
laura si sia 94 un bell'otto per due ore
volte qualcosa un cecchino grazie alle
molte reti moscarella in questo momento
che io farei così
niente o che come si restringe la zona è
ma mi sa che dobbiamo ripartire subito
mi risulta il più velocemente possibile
perché ciò che riguarda gli oil gas il
gas è arrivato già il tempo fatta sei
proprio che poi cinque mesi stringerà
non so sicuramente non solo
oh oh che bel visti lo vuole e non so
neanche troppo distante c'erano che
poteva essere chissà dove l'ottimismo è
il profumo delle radiazioni ma sicuro vs
esso vuole no fa cagare
scusi in vacca care sks fa
sono emozionato mi dà il cecchino amico
però treni da e per otto scusami proprio
grazie se una persona mi ricorderò di te
altra visto sei proprio gentile oggi
qualcuno ma vedere come su quello con le
sue veloci e nociglia secam passa in più
lascia un fermaglio c'è un bel po a che
livello 3 e te lo lascio perché se una
persona molto buona ha veramente del 64
8 di tutto il ks cose e la mia come
qualcosa tipo estate si sono un pò tanti
però il bomber 6 caproni ca 1 tappandole
league dopo sacra terra perché prima di
un'occasione per cena giovane non è che
il ponza perché se avessimo giocato
poi ho giocato sono scema la brutta era
che fu il mercato quasi non fa per me
non so perché la portata di queste
compassione se caproni semplicemente
dato lo dico prima a te veramente
alla benzina dentro i secchi che se so
bene che qualche ai perché tormentato
come scelta volesse in testa della
ragione subito che è bello e siamo
subito allora invece di fare in quegli
anni guardiamo un attimo dove dove
potremo andare robot sto facendo io sto
girando il 16 la notte come niente così
trovato soppresso non quello scalari le
mattonelle silenziato allo studio bene
io vi amo che ci sono stati passi in
mezzo perche per il mio si è capito
sarei contento la prendi una macchina
vieni a prendere più iscritti vicino ti
serata la tanica non andavano celo celo
la padella
ma ovviamente io però anche una sola
rimasta viamente gira così ma cosa ho
solo lavoro a luglio ma quanta gente
abito palermo nel 1626 rinati anche
interrotta la casa scende andiamo ce la
fa della pace ai
tutto ciò è un s 12 k ti interessano
no potrebbe esserci un problema di
minuto
no no no no non viene incassata da una
tuta mazzo tranquillo ci penso io
ovvero scopo pietro che dietro ma sei
malato ma e le malattie ma le malattie
questo ma sei scemo incastra la moto è
una bomba
c'è un bobby jones ha nei giornali ovvio
mica sono da vari ammazzato funzione
come cazzo hai fatto ma tu sei stupido
no adesso sta adesso ti fermi mi spieghi
come incassato la moto in un barile
io sto al barile quello romano in belgio
ma che problemi guido io no video zitto
quindi no perché ti sei nella posizione
di poter decidere se guidare vado anche
morire un sito sito entra veloce arriva
l'ace ginocchio apparati l'avete mila
segnalino arriverà come si è proprio 6
pregando verso la mecca non bello figo
c'è la macchina che mi interessa
parecchio
[Risate]
dove andiamo ma dove hai messo mano a
segno il nome assunzione minutoli
bettino dove dobbiamo andare no le
magliette faccio io la faccio io no
[Risate]
ora sto rifacendo cercando di capire se
secondo il cecchino fa vedere se
ha senso fare
hai guidato da te parcheggio
ok
vediamo come la situa sly per favi
looking for viene mai un cazzo di niente
[Musica]
non mi sciocca
se però così col bisogno
ma da allora nascosta l'accesso per la
sensi sento che mi sto concentrati ma
quando fai il parcheggio che deve
abbassare la musica da fare per
parcheggiare meglio c'è una macchina
libera ai gay tardi spiegami perchè vi
di ritoccare il mama world cup si è
spaventato andiamo averlo no ci vai tu a
land no no no no spara le volte sei
ferma stiamo parte che tu dovresti
controlla dietro fa qualcosa di caccia
rianda le foci inculano dai un occhio
dato si è ristretta qui quindi perfetto
perché abbiamo cecchino dobbiamo andare
a cuba dall'alto è l'unica quale ora
dovete messo a segno di noi abbiamo a
darvi ok
aspetta
controllava se da mesi che c'è qualcuno
lì c'era una macchina appena dove ha
fatto sparare per lutto trans dov'è il
sapore ed era di qualcuno che l'ha
mollata e non capisco il perché
343 live ancora 43 persone vive più noi
29 con i due compresi il 41 persone sono
ancora tanti però più di metà partita
già siamo fatta
ce ne sono
e mica mirato un gabbiano che sembrava
un aereo questo che si chiudessero gli
elicotteri i suoi giocolieri se il
casinò
basta diamo mancate dentro secondi prima
ancora farci mezzo all'acqua lo sai se
sei in macchina
[__]
e per madonna ti vedo la giugulare quel
colle
ma perché passi dal ponte
no vabbè ormai sei lì da non per questo
dal bordino l'ha mai amata ormai sei lì
però mica cari e rigirato da quella
parte della macchina volare per liguria
ma
musiche di cole anomala
l'hockey gli ha dato la patente a questo
sai non seguite con noi la prossima
volta non ci vengo dovrà quindi con la
macchina non mi accompagni più nessuna
parte che cagà
e partito solo ieri schermata piega
una spada
stiamo andando non è precisamente di
fermare però vai vai vai di qua
sistemazione a fermarci mai dati
mica se qua qua donna che kakà vai vai
vai continuo di non ti fermare perché
c'è gesù cristo bye bye bye bye bye bye
bye bye bye continua continua
non sulla roccia pietro hashish indice
in pasta se in pericolo su stamattina
non sull'assoluta sulla roccia abbiamo
parker e sopra la roccia breve arriva il
gas quando un occhio che c'è gente che
arriva da lì si sta sparando ma di me lo
sono altrettanto anni tutta la macchina
occhio che siano dietro il gas copri
dietro che un cecchino coprire io guardo
chi arriva nessuno aveva a lungo
la macchina è lasciata lì dietro
complimenti si vabbè non vedo nessuno
ancora mi spiega la seco si sicuro sì ma
dove
penso
oh cazzo eccoli a ieri spara ad allora
sì dove spari no no è entrato nel gas
via via dai 34 live vai vai alle vie di
partenza che ancora oggi
sempre non guarda la zona è sempre
opposta o poi nostra valle minchia
giochino mille occhi dobbiamo avere
perché primo che si muove in groppa
deretano guardi siamo anche lontani
porca vacca e decori corti fermare sono
lontanissimi gli ometti perché hai
parcheggiato la macchina fuori dalla
zona tumore che lascio la guida si ma
lascia la quale senso fermati che 5
così facendo un cazzo alla guerra del
golfo 28 vivi ricorrere con un beduino
morto poi cittadino anche non cagare
nessuno sapeva di via macchia chi ci fa
eco lontana e mori quando è morto e
molte altre volte molte morti solo lui
c'era
occhio che ci stiamo andando sul metodo
secondo me siamo da volerlo schivarlo
dai sebbene stare il panino la faccia
mai vivo si farà e sparito
no oil gas salvati salvati saldati con i
morti ma potremo sapere io voto prima
che sarà fissata si chiama ti va bene
così non importa dice vai a lavorare qui
vai salvati non pensare a me e la [__]
quando arriva a casa
se nella 6 tratterà con vicinissima
finire che sopravvivo di più io che te
anche se la morte stelle ti seguo
[__] ho provato a schivarlo
17 leidyi pietro dai catalani non fa il
culo occhio dai clienti
è un attimo questo quanto e casso il
luogo aveva tutto lo statico pinocchio
muoviti mentre lui perché se ti sparano
non si muove sta fermo prosciolta ma
preferisco essere ammesse fermo uno di
mira sei molto quindi ce l'hai veloce ma
da quanto tempo questa è la mia
riportando un motore a chi è morto che
vivo capelli se è morto perché ero
distratto gli altri mentre di investirlo
sono morto vabbè primo vero il giro fa
al mio sta rimontando il mobile del ii
piano sta riguardando 14 aid aids e in
finale quasi ancora 4 e 6 finale
secondo me ci chiama abbandonato la
macchina lì perché ne capisco faccia
spari comunque 12 dei casi ancora adese
in finale ed è bravo l'abbiamo un po di
punti e prendiamo la gonnellina [__]
altre 100 euro di don io se avete
qualcosa dopo di cocchio che c'è a
destra packaging
non posso dimettermi se è bello perché
non ho gente messa malissimo maya o
malissimo
che sarà brolo giusto della pietra buona
team ha guardati in cui girano a caso
fiducia sulla fiducia ai bambini
cammina cammina pirla ti sente così
10 lines in finale
come ti senti non so se forse timoroso
abbiamo accovacciati a metterla così non
è tempo di reazione
se la stessa
e qui soprattutto con cristo e qua sotto
per forza ma dov'è ecco il più avanti è
così sapere qui e ventola e quindi poi
spara in spagna in spider man show che
lo sciopero madonna che kakà scampo beh
corrie ordinari tregua di pensare a cosa
fare cori via se parma roccia
però vorrei che cosa gli ormai questa
macro ed il fascino enya c'è stato ma
trova quale radici sotto la mappa porca
vacca sesti su 47 timbro di tenere ma
conduce moro puntare all'altro montorio
international chi non importa io direi
che il nostro buon pietro ha fatto
quanto di possibile per poter portare
avanti il nome degli italiani in questa
partita di sarebbe infatti bisogno di un
pugno per caso prospettiva allora
ragazzi spero che questo video vi sia
piaciuto abbiamo fatto un po di di 13
stratos traffico ci tiriamo fuori magari
sei lì dalla bella roba dice soprattutto
il tipo che si è fermato che non mai
ucciso è stato bellissimo
ebbene siamo andati male dai poteva
andare meglio prova è andata bene anche
player non batte il ground ragazzi spero
che vi sia piaciuto cose
non mi piace ma ciò è vero che questo
non è un video normale euro presto bene
e visto parlare è mai pronto in
trasferta dove sia piaciuto ragazzi con
sé che mi piace anche ad isolamento resi
da sotto poi si siede e non ci vediamo
al solito da ragazzi